é uma satisfação muito grande estar aqui
com vocês
é nessa primeira participação minha
nesse evento que eu reputo ser um dos
mais importantes para todos nós porque
pode exatamente contribuir com uma série
de transformações pelos insetos que são
dados aqui não é
e por que vocês também são parte da
elite intelectual dessa nossa sociedade
brasileira da sociedade amazonense são
tomadores de decisões importantes que de
repente pode fazer a grande diferença
para a melhoria do nosso país da nossa
sociedade
mas eu vou procurar deixar para vocês
algumas reflexões importantes porque a
partir de agora eu sei que dentro disso
que eu reputo é importante para o
amazonas
eu vou passar a ter outros aliados a
partir de agora eu quero dizer que o
nosso estado tem uma riqueza muito
concentrada em manaus na capital em
torno de 77 por cento do que a gente
produz está aqui na capital e quando eu
coloco 44 manacapuru e parintins que
representa 7% somando tudo isso chego a
exatos 84.8 por cento
ora só olhar esses números nós já
podemos concluir que estamos diante de
um grande desafio para promover o
desenvolvimento da nossa região porque
tu tens uma grande concentração de
riqueza e um grande bolsão porque não
dizer aqui entre nós de pobreza então eu
costumo ter a convicção de que nós somos
um povo que encaminhamos pisando em
milhões e milhões de reais
mas nós não sabemos até porque nosso
país ainda e os professores que estão
aqui me ajudem a pensar nosso país ainda
não entendeu muito bem a diferença entre
educação e ensino
nós não estamos educando nosso povo não
estamos ensinando e ensinando ainda
dentro de uma necessidade muito abaixo
daquela que de fato nós precisamos e com
mais tempo poderia comentar isso porque
então nós precisamos evoluir muito na
educação do nosso povo para que ele
possa entender questões como essa onde
eu tenho aí
apenas nesta região que é o marco ali 80
praticamente 4 84% toda a riqueza
concentrada e o restante do nosso estado
o que fazer né como é que eu vou educar
como é que eu vou ensinar o meu povo
para entender que a riqueza que nós
estamos aí eu coloco apenas um exemplo
você está ouvindo muito fala nisso nós
temos 98% de todo o nióbio de toda a
reserva de nióbio do mundo em nosso
estado do amazonas e são gabriel da
cachoeira nós temos em torno de 24% e
sem óbvio a indústria aeroespacial em 2
ter o náutico fica comprometida mas
porque não somos nós que damos os preços
que lideramos esse mercado internacional
que nós não sabemos disso não educamos o
nosso povo para entender isso
então nós precisamos promover essa
revolução mas de forma social e
ambientalmente correta não preciso dizer
isso eu estou na amazônia então tem que
promover esse desenvolvimento
respeitando esse equilíbrio não é
ecológico enfim
mas aí está colocado um grande desafio
que é exatamente nós entendemos muito
bem isso e entender essa mudança pode
vir a partir do momento em que eu
consigo entender as riquezas que eu
tenho e trabalhar para agregar valor a
essas riquezas que nós temos porque nós
ainda vendemos e consumimos e natura um
exemplo muito tradicional ea própria
propunha que todo mundo conhece mas o
que nós fazemos é apenas cozinhar tomar
com café praticamente nada mais
agora uma tas toneladas de trigo
eu uso hoje para fabricar pão com
quantas toneladas de pizza nós
consumimos e nós sabemos fazer farinha a
partir do punho limpa tem essa
tecnologia vem o doutor rua porque não
transformamos isso numa linha de
produção social e ambientalmente correta
por isso eu digo que fiquei muito feliz
com o que eu vi nas colocações doutor lá
porque vai ao irão de encontro àquilo
que também nós defendemos neste dia aqui
que é exatamente entender melhor o que
nós temos
eu ainda vivo gente é questões do tipo
eu chego na feira que eu viajo nossos
municípios todos
né pra conviver pra exatamente entender
esse lado antropológico da nossa
sociedade entender porque nós não
despertamos para a questão comercial
para a questão do lucro e ainda ouço
muito dizer assim olha tem como o aço aí
o que é que os não tem porque não está
na época
sim eu não posso agregar valor para ter
o cupuaçu ano todo porque a natureza já
fez a parte dela porque eu não faço a
minha passa por a questão da educação
então eu preciso entender todo esse
conjunto de riquezas que eu tenho pra
sair desse estágio gente quando eu penso
numa atividade econômica social e
ambientalmente correto para os 61
municípios fora de manaus
eu penso que esse processo é muito caro
e não é competitivo transportar a nossa
produção desta forma a organizar os
nossos centros de venda desse jeito não
nos torna competitivo até porque o
índice de rejeito é muito grande para em
vocês pra pensar o quanto nós estragamos
ao longo da cadeia produtiva que é outra
coisa que nós não entendemos ainda nós
temos o ajax até política pública só
contempla um ponto da cadeia produtiva
que a produção mas esquece do suprimento
esquece da distribuição esquece da
logística reversa é o que a gente vê
como eu já presenciei em manicoré por
exemplo o nosso acabou com sua produção
de melancia na beira do rio e chega um
comerciante diz olha o do r$40 centavos
uma pela outra
dá vontade de chorar e você chega na
feira compra 15 20 reais de reais uma
melancia
como vamos mudar isso eu quero
compartilhar com vocês esses desafios
para profissionalizar isso e aí eu
preciso a partir da educação educar o
nosso pessoal para agregar valor e temos
muitos como agregar valor olha melancia
com essa técnica como é que ela produz
facilita o transporte
quantos eventos nós organizamos como
esse são eventos que de repente se eu
agrego valor
eu vou fazer uma mesa com isso aqui eu
estou pensando diferente da minha grande
mensagem que eu quero compartilhar com
vocês é olhar diferente o que eu vejo
hoje que eu possa partir
vai quebrar alguns paradigmas por
exemplo a minha mãe disse muito pra mim
meu filho estude para arranjar um bom
emprego e obediente bom filho fez
graduação especialização mestrado
doutorado foi pra europa defende tudo
mas pra minha geração hoje para os meus
filhos hoje no meu filho estude para
montar o seu próprio negócio
empreendedor desmon e não preparar uma
geração para ser empregado nada contra
mas dada as potencialidades que nós
temos nós precisamos de mais pessoas que
olham os nossos recursos e monte o seu
próprio negócio
aí é só a própria riqueza fica mais
socializada isso é bom pra todo mundo
entende as potencialidades são grandes
então nós aí estaríamos quebrando esse
paradigma né e criando coisas novas eu
estava gravando um programa no amazon
sat zona de desenvolvimento e participei
de uma feira onde alunos de 2º grau de
tefé fizeram café a partir daquele
coquinho do tucumã e eu tomei só que
antes de tomar o fez um exercício de
tentar pagar os registros que eu tenho
do café tradicional para poder entender
ficafé e gostei
agora qualquer que isso não se torna um
produto lá inter fé não aqui e que gera
emprego e renda lá assim como outras
culturas que nós temos
entendi então é uma questão de nós e
incentivarmos esse tipo de de trabalho
porque as potencialidades tão grande
a mesma coisa aqui temos castanha mas
qual como que a gente agrega valor
não temos um produto e assim eu morei
uma época fora por conta do doutorado e
quando se falava e amazona o amazônia
gente é uma marca forte de fato é uma
marca forte apesar de eles olharem
amazônia caiu uma folha estão desmatando
não pode calma mas é uma marca forte
então se a gente conseguir aqui imaginar
essa questão do empreendedorismo que né
falou e daí nós criarmos empresa social
e ambientalmente correta espalhada
explorando as potencialidades de cada
município
aí nós vamos promover uma revolução
gente eu quero que vocês pensem sobre
isso porque é uma revolução porque o
principal pagador hoje nos nossos
municípios quem é o prefeito com
dinheiro público pensar nisso e na
medida em que o município consegue ter a
sua identidade econômica fabricar e
vender produtos a uma queda nessa
dependência a uma autonomia para a
sociedade ea partir daí esse dinheiro
que vai para a folha de pagamento
poderia ir para a saúde a educação pra
infraestrutura e na folha de pagamento
entendi então pra mim eu vejo isso como
uma verdadeira revolução
e aí eu não contente com o que eu vivo
na minha região e como o ministro aula
em santa catarina eu peguei meus alunos
de core e levei para lá a gente que
nunca tinha viajado de avião foi pra
chapecó xaxim
achei aquela região toda pra ver um
processo de produção de milho gerenciado
em toda a cadeia produtiva fugindo
daquela visão departamentalizada onde
cada um faz o seu esquece do todo esse é
o perfil profissional que não atende
muito e aí essa questão da educação vai
fazer com que eu faça o meu caboclo
nelmon se entender que assim eu não sou
competitivo e que assim eu não estou
agregando valor necessário para
transforma isso em um produto
competitivo né
e a partir daí com essa educação ele vai
entender que a gestão precisa ter assim
em toda a cadeia isso inclusive para os
decisores que a partir de então vão
fazer políticas públicas não voltada só
para produção como eu já vi em vários
municípios aí eu não resisto
quando eu vejo lá a gente a gente do
governo emprestando 2 mil 3 mil reais
para um produtor eu não consigo ver isso
eu chego converso mostra que está errado
que provavelmente aquele produtor não
vai investir no setor produtivo é
provável que ele
seu cigarrinho o seu a seu cigarro a sua
fé o seu café uma televisão porque é
necessidade básica quem estudou as
pirâmides ea pirâmide das necessidade
abraão mas não sabe disso
e aí eu estou incentivando a produção
mas seu sofrimento cada informação é
matéria prima para ele cada distribuição
para ele depender menos dos
atravessadores não tem isso não está
correto então a política pública precisa
ser visto dentro de uma visão sistêmica
do meio à visão holística e é evidente
que mudar tudo isso não é fácil porque
nós estamos lidando com cultura e não
segunda cultura do dia para a noite
cultura é sempre esse trabalho talvez de
uma geração para a outra com o trabalho
constante não pontual como esses alunos
viram lá em santa catarina como mesmo em
macapá antes de ontem eu falei isso eu
digo gente vocês estão consumindo aqui
produtos da aurora produtos da sadia
fabricados lá no interior de santa
catarina
agora porque que eles lá não consome os
produtos que vocês produzem aqui porque
vocês não enxergam um mercado que tem lá
porque nós aqui também não enxergamos os
potenciais desse mercado
e aí fica uma dica gente investir em
biotecnologia eu vejo como uma das
saídas para nós
veja bem a natureza nos deu o maior
laboratório que nós podemos ter que a
nossa floresta e eu converso eu quantas
vezes já não tive conversa na beira no
beiradão com o nosso caboclo humilde
descalço de caução dando uma verdadeira
aula de como utilizar os recursos da
amazônia chega lá e diz olha eu tô com
uma dor de barriga ou eu tô com isso com
aquela doença como andes o que ele diz
calma menino pega ali um arraes a casca
de um pau faz o remédio e funciona esse
é um conhecimento tradicional quem sabe
até milenar nosso imagina no dia em que
nós evoluirmos ao ponto de montar
temos equipes com as universidades com o
governo do estado onde o mestre e
doutores vão conversar com esse nosso
caboclo e ele vai nos dar exatamente o
que obama falou eu vou identificar o
princípio ativo daquela casca aquela
folha
vou transformar isso então uma pomada
uma pílula e vou vender isso esse
conhecimento já está lá
nós ainda não despertamos nós ainda não
aprendemos a usar isso e esta linha de
produção repito de forma social e
ambientalmente correta seria lá e não
aqui porque aqui nós já estamos com
praticamente 80 e um ponto 3 por cento
de toda a riqueza de todo o pib
concentrado aqui
isso gera uma série de problemas para
nós então a gestão deste processo gente
algo desafio um desafio e nós temos que
vencer porque nós estamos ainda é de
certa forma pagando um preço que é do
brasil inteiro
todos nós temos problemas é vocês
percebem os problemas que nós temos na
educação na saúde no transporte e na
infraestrutura na segurança problema de
gestão
nós gerenciamos mal os nossos recurso e
na amazônia não é diferente mas eu não
posso desistir não
o desafio é grande gente mas eu preciso
encontrar os meios de continuar vendo o
tom isso em outro que eu conheço
precisam continuar isso para que nós
possamos ter junto à sua iniciativa com
atua em termos de desenvolver o lado
empreendedor que uma próxima geração
pense no seu próprio negócio e não
necessariamente se programar já para os
empregados dos outros nada contra mas é
que pelas potencialidades que nós temos
aqui eu tenho convicção de que nós somos
as pessoas certas no lugar certo para
ganhar dinheiro
não temos vergonha de dizer isso não é
afinal de contas os nossos filhos têm o
péssimo hábito de comer todo dia não é
isso
então nós temos que ganhar dinheiro
nós temos que fazer história nós estamos
no lugar certo e somos as pessoas certas
para isso aqui
eu fui convidado para falar sobre as
questões que nós temos de logística como
foi colocado um pouco e realmente
desafio é grande e aí eu fui lá em
brasília discute isso mostrar o quanto
nós dependemos da dos rios para
transportar é assim eu tiro foto porque
estou lançando um livro sobre isso eu
estou filmando e vivendo a nossa
realidade para escrever esse livro e
aqui está o que eu disse tem um dedinho
de prosa com esse povo é que ele vai te
ensinar muita coisa que realmente vai
gerar produtos ea partir daí a gente vai
enxergar o universo maior e vender esses
produtos a questão para encerrar que eu
quero deixar é gente o que é que nós
queremos em o que é que nós queremos
sair eu preciso que vocês me ajudem a
responder essas duas perguntas fica pra
vocês aí já no final da minha
apresentação
o que compõem a base da nossa economia
da economia dos municípios e qual é a
identidade econômica para cada um dos
nossos municípios
nós ainda não temos resposta para isso
cada município tem condição natural a
partir da preparação do seu pessoal e da
construção da infraestrutura de
transporte de ter a sua fonte de renda e
depender menos do poder público e as
interessa o que chama de revolução que
essa libertação do nosso pessoal gente
deixa essa reflexão então pra vocês
agradeceu o convite e ficamos à
disposição para uma próxima oportunidade
muito obrigado